il est impossible d'isoler la russie la
déclaration ce matin de vladimir poutine
le président russe qui s'exprimait lors
d'un forum économique
il a parlé je cite des élites
occidentales dominé par les états unis
le simple fait qu'il appelle l'occident
a arrêté les sanctions au motif qu'elle
ne serait pas efficace et qu'elle
pèserait davantage sur l'europe sur la
russie
nous incite à considérer qu'elles ne
sont efficaces s'il vous faut des
chiffres vous en avez
le pib de la russie baisse tout le monde
dit que la russie utilise l'énergie
comme une arme aux jeunes encore d
absurde justice quelle arme utilisons
nous
nous fournissons autant que nécessaire
en fonction des demandes de nos
partenaires autant qu'ils le demandent
c'est la quantité que nous livrons 28
euros et pas un centime de plus selon
une étude pics paix c'est la moyenne
d'argent de poche perçu en normandie
nous voulons rendre notre marché du
travail plus efficace plus juste plus
flexible mais aussi plus protecteur plus
flexible ça signifie que lorsque la
période est propice au plein-emploi
lorsqu'il ya beaucoup d'emplois
disponibles à pourvoir et bien le régime
de protection d'assurance chômage doit
être plus incitatif pour aller chercher
un emploi la corse serait la région la
plus généreuse avec en moyenne 50 euros
d'argent de poche par mois on ne vous
souhaite pas en france d'un prince
modèle canadien qui est un modèle
régressif
et si vous faites ça c'est les
gouvernants marché vous fait ça mais les
gens vont en subir les conséquences les
papas serait aussi plus généreux que les
mamans avec 8 euros de plus en moyenne
pour les enfants qu'on est moins radin
mais papa sont généreux exactement on a
un grand coeur nous le taux de chômage
au canada détermine aussi si vous avez
le droit à une allocation si le chômage
est à plus de 13% 420 heures suffisent
pour être éligible à l'envers ce camp le
taux de chômage est bas moins de 6% il
faut avoir travaillé au moins 700 heures
pour prétendre à une indemnité ex député
centriste de seine saint denis jean
christophe lagarde interpellé ce matin
et placés en garde à vue il est
interrogé dans la sphère sur les fausses
accusations fin juin des députés elle
est fille raquel garrido et alexis
corbière qui auraient exploité une femme
de ménage sans papiers à leur domicile
en région parisienne sont des propos
évidemment que je n'étais pas le moment
de faire je le regrette aujourd'hui on
ne peut pas faire de l'humour
c'était une blague de mauvaise qualité
pas au bon moment comme dans les procès
staliniens ou via au milieu après pour
faire pour s'excuser de ce qu'on m'a dit
fais et quand on dit des bêtises non
mais j'aime bien ce côté mea culpa
christophe galtier avait ironisé en
conférence de presse lundi sur le
recours aux chars à voile dans les
déplacements des joueurs au lieu d'
avion privé très émetteurs de carbone
c'est important qu'il réalise dans quel
monde on est qu'ils prennent conscience
qu'il ya une crise climatique qui n'est
plus une hypothèse pour demain mais qui
est une réalité maintenant qu'on a tous
vécu avec la canicule avec la sécheresse
avec les incendies on continue à avoir
un président de la république qui
continue à jouer et churchill on est en
guerre mais n'est pas churchill qui veut
dire churchill quand il faisait son
discours après les pas faire du jet ski
voici la nouvelle ministre de la santé
britannique et vice première ministre
pas vraiment à son avantage mais comme
le veut l'adage internet n'oublie jamais
les voies et moyens pour y parvenir ne
passe pas forcément par des obligations
des interdictions de stade nous laissons
ça à d'autres
confrères tous les débats qui ont
émaillé ces dernières semaines sur les
barbecues les piscines et et que sais-je
149 euros par an par ménage c'est
l'économie qu'on peut réaliser si on
limite notre vitesse sur les routes par
exemple 110 km heure au lieu de 130 sur
l'autoroute un autre ministre appelée
par les skrulls fait également parler de
lui
beaucoup d'internautes jack aubry ce
blog le nouveau ministre du commerce de
l'industrie et de l'énergie c'est ce
député affalé au parlement lors des
discussions sur le grill site en 2019
une attitude jugée alors nonchalante
arrogante et détourné sur les réseaux
sociaux